hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear movie review show
so i'm sure that anybody that's really
into horror uh is probably familiar with
the work of the english screenwriter and
director
ben wheatley now i covered a couple of
his films previously a kill list from
2011
and a field in england from 2013.
now it seems that those are kind of like
his best-known horror ones and
in the years since 2013 uh which i
actually wasn't even all that aware of
he's actually con kind of gone on to do
more like bigger budget sort of like
action movies or like kind of like
british black comedy type of movies
and the next project that he's gonna do
actually is you guys remember that big
like giant shark movie the meg which was
actually like pretty entertaining ben
wheatley is going to direct the sequel
to that apparently that has jason
statham in it and that's coming out in
2023.
so there's that but it does seem that
last year
in 2021 during the uh kovid lockdown the
initial lockdowns
ben wheatley decided that he was going
to sort of like go back to his roots i
guess uh so to speak
and make another one of his kind of like
trippy like folk horror type of like
independent films
so the movie that he came out with in
2021 was called in the earth
and it premiered at sundance back in
early 2021 and then i believe neon
picked it up and uh gave it a wider
release
now i have to say um it's on hulu at the
moment if you have hula and i'm sure
it's streaming elsewhere i watched it on
hulu
i have to say right out the gate that i
didn't love this one as much as i did
his other two that i previously
mentioned field in england and kill list
but i will say that there's actually
like enough great stuff here that
i really wouldn't hesitate to recommend
if you like his other movies you will
probably like this one as well
because he has a very specific style and
that is very very evident in this movie
too
now in the earth probably bears the
closest resemblance to a field in
england it has kind of a lot of the same
like sort of kaleidoscopic like
hallucinogenic
like flashy type of imagery it also has
kind of like a pagan nature kind of
theme to it as well like a folk horror
kind of theme and also happens to have
uh reese shearsmith in a major role who
if you remember was also in a field in
england he was like the main part in
that
uh unlike a field in england though
in the earth is uh in color it's not in
black and white
it's uh takes place pretty much entirely
in a forest rather than in a field or
like out in the open and it's set in the
present day
now there are also kind of some sort of
passing similarities with his other
movie kill list mostly in terms of kind
of like the violence there's like it's
it's not like a violent movie per se but
there is like a lot of i guess you would
sort of call it body horror but a lot of
it is just kind of like you know like
close-ups of like gross ass wounds and
injuries and [ __ ] like that like really
gross injuries like people getting their
toes cut off and whatnot and as far as
another film like not from ben wheatley
that would be sort of like in the same
ballpark as in you know if you like this
movie might like that one as well was uh
annihilation so if you liked
annihilation this is kind of like
thematically similar to that as well so
the story centers around this scientist
named martin lowry and he's played by
joel fry
and i immediately recognized him and i
was like why do i recognize that actor
he was in that movie from 2019 called
yesterday you know like the one where
the beatles never existed like you know
the the alternate timeline yeah he was
in that so that's where i recognized him
from so he plays like the main character
so at the beginning of the movie he's
shown kind of like arriving at this
remote government outpost of some kind
it's like some kind of like
ecological or it's some kind of
scientific thing they're like on the
edge of this forest and blah blah so
it's that kind of thing
and it's drizzling rain and all this
other stuff now there's apparently just
like in real life a pandemic raging
throughout the country presumably the
world i don't really know if it's uh
really that relevant
now the pandemic in the movie does have
some similarities like you can tell that
they're you know because like i said i'm
pretty sure they shot this like in and
around the lockdowns
um there are some similarities in that
everybody's kind of wearing masks and
you have to like be you have your
temperature taken and stuff like that
but it doesn't seem to be the same thing
like it seems to be some other kind of
pandemic which is maybe i don't know
because a few times like you know some
of the people like get sprayed down with
stuff and you know i mean it's like much
more like a
decontamination type of thing with like
uh you know hazmat suits and everything
like that so it's kind of like
i don't know so it's so it's not exactly
the same thing but they're using that as
like a jumping off point and the
implication too is that maybe the
disease whatever it is like i said they
don't i don't think they ever really say
what it is might have something to do
with the scientific work that dr lowry
has come out there to like see about you
know what i'm saying now the character
of dr lowry is like actually really
interesting because
he's kind of like when he first shows up
he's kind of like mysterious like not
not in a sinister type of way like you
can tell that he's not a bad guy
but
his motives are like a little bit
unclear i guess or a little bit murky
he's very very soft-spoken he seems a
little awkward like socially awkward or
something like that he's just very quiet
and it's kind of obvious like right from
the jump that he's maybe not being
entirely truthful
regarding like what his exact reasons
are for like being here you know what
i'm saying
now ostensibly he has been sent by you
know the research foundation that he
works for and that's i think that part's
true but i'm just like you know there's
other things going on
so he's been sent out here
to check up on the work of a colleague
of his
who he worked with very closely like at
some time in the past and her name is dr
olivia wendell she's played by haley
squires who i also immediately
recognized she was in
in fabric that movie from 2018 which i
absolutely loved but yeah that's where i
recognized her from i think she was in
uh ken loach's latest movie uh too if
i'm not a mistake so dr olivia wendell
had set up camp it was like a couple of
days like in this forest i think it's
near bristol is where it's supposed to
be but in this forest like a couple of
days walk from the you know the ranger
station or the outpost or whatever
and she actually hasn't been responding
to
letters or you know radio contact or
anything like that for a few months so
they're wondering like what she's up to
out there
now dr wendell's work had to do with
she was trying to like increase uh crop
efficiency
by researching the symbiotic
relationship between like plants and
fungi
and she's apparently been studying this
really big underground network of
interconnected like plant and fungal
life
and this she says it might be the
largest in the country like 30 square
miles i think they say at one point and
she also you kind of find out later she
suspects that it may operate essentially
like a sentient organism so dr lowry uh
he's at the ranger station getting ready
to go out you know to dr wendell's camp
to see what's going on out there and
he's going to be accompanied by this
park ranger park scout something like
that named alma and she is played by
elora torchia i think that's how you
pronounce her last name uh she was
actually in mid-summer she played connie
and she tells him like he notices this
weird like very mid-summery actually uh
poster like on the wall and he's like
what what is this about and then there's
like all these kids drawings of like
different kinds of like monsters or like
witchy kind of creatures and stuff and
she says oh that's just like a local
legend um it's like a spirit of the
woods type figure called parnag feg
which is sort of like yeah like yeah we
just use it as a story to like keep the
kids out of the woods so they don't like
throw garbage all over the place or
whatever they don't trash it but yeah so
it's kind of like a i don't know if it's
like a mother earth or like an earth
goddess type of or some kind of like
earth spirit there's something like that
but it's supposed to be like this local
legend
so the two of them set out and they she
said it's gonna be like a two day hike
now along the journey martin and alma
come across a couple of like unsettling
things like out in the woods
one of the most unsettling is that they
find the abandoned remains of a camp
that appeared to have been occupied by a
family quite recently but obviously
they're all gone now they're like
there's like some kids toys and like so
whoever had this camp like took off or
whatever and alma says yeah we've had
like a few people come hiking out here
because apparently it's like a nature
preserve like so people come out there
like from time to time and they said
yeah like some people have been
disappearing and we're not entirely sure
why so the pair keep moving along um
they're going a little bit slower maybe
than alma would like because she keeps
kind of like going a little bit ahead
and then turn around being like what the
[ __ ] man you're taking forever
and the reason for this is that martin
who actually when he first arrived at
the outpost and they'd like sprayed him
down with the deconf decontaminant and
he handed over his papers which i assume
was like vaccination or a health record
or something like that and they did like
a sort of like uh you know rudimentary
sort of examination
and
he said i mean he supposedly had a clean
bill of health but like when he's out
here he said oh he well first thing he
says i told the doctor that i've been
exercising look the whole time that i'd
been in quarantine because he said he'd
been quarantined um but he's like i lied
about that so he's like i'm really out
of shape uh also he seems to have kind
of like cold symptoms a little bit like
he's sneezing and stuff um even though
again supposedly he was disease free and
another thing is that he seems to have
ringworm even though like the doctor at
the outpost before he left was like oh
it looks like you had ringworm and he's
like yeah that cleared up like a week
ago but clearly it did not
so he's kind of like a little bit he's
not sick sick but he's just like a
little bit under the weather and so he's
going like a little bit slow so it's
taking them like a little bit longer to
get out there than maybe they had
intended
uh you also find out during the course
of these sort of like halting
conversations that like martin and alma
are having
that maybe there's a possibility that
martin and dr wendell were maybe more
than friends and uh and acquaintances
and colleagues that maybe there was
something like kind of more romantic
going on and it comes to light that he
had actually been corresponding with her
like quite voluminously like for a
really long time
and uh you know that was one of the
things that he wanted to volunteer to
come out and find her because the
letters had stopped a few months ago and
he's kind of like worried about what
happened to her
so you know but he's still being kind of
like cagey he's not real saying a lot of
stuff
so finally they bed down for the night
they've got all their camping gear and
stuff like that because they had planned
for you know this two-day hike but then
things take kind of a startling turn in
the middle of the night they both get
attacked
by some unseen perpetrator or
perpetrators
who kind of like tears their campsite
apart and steals a few things from the
campsite but most notably their shoes
so uh so they kind of get beat up and
they wake up they they go unconscious
like on the forest floor there
and they they wake up the next morning
and they're like really confused they're
a little bit hurt but not super hurt
they're like who would have assaulted us
like that like why did they just take
our shoes i think they took a couple of
things that um that martin had like in a
case that he had with him like some kind
of equipment they took that too but it
was mostly like the shoes they didn't
take hardly anything else uh and they
don't really know like why they were
targeting in particular and then they
were kind of like well maybe this is
what happened to like some of the people
that disappeared like earlier on in the
woods they're not entirely sure but
they're like well you know we're almost
to dr wendell's camp now so we might as
well like keep on going
uh since he doesn't have any shoes
though
uh martin just a little way down the
track uh steps on something and slices
his foot wide open like pretty it's
pretty [ __ ] gruesome this is another
one i'm saying it's more like um
there's a lot of that kind of stuff in
this movie with like gross ass injuries
you know what i mean that you kind of
like see like close up you know what i
mean
uh so yeah so okay so he cuts his foot
open they don't really have a lot of
their equipment so he kind of has to you
know alma finds him this big branch and
he's kind of like hobbling along like
you know using it for a crutch
now luckily for them or so it seems
they soon stumble across
this kind of bearded
dude
just sitting in the woods
now this guy's name is zach and he's
played by uh reese shearsmith
and he says um you know yeah i've been
living illegal because this is
government lands you're not really
supposed to like squat on it or whatever
but he's like yeah i've been living out
here for a little while
and martin and alma are like well you
know we won't tell if you won't uh you
know what i mean it's like
you know we'll promise not to tell on
you and he's like okay and he seems like
really nice and accommodating and he's
like i got some stuff back at the camp
he's like i probably have even some like
extra shoes or clothes and some medical
supplies and stuff like that so he's
like so come along and i'll feed you and
fix you right up so they go
and at first uh everything seems pretty
copacetic like he makes him like a
really nice stew out of like some forage
that he had he seems to have like you
know some spare shoes around that kind
of fit them
and uh you know he just he just seems
like a really nice uh nice guy he even
sews up this gaping wound in martin's
foot which is like super super gross
he's like yeah it's flopping around i
don't know why that made me laugh so
hard when he said that that it was when
he said something
it's flapping around or flopping around
or something like that because it's a
big flap of skin like off the bottom of
his foot it's super gross um but yeah so
everything seems super copacetic at once
but you know this is a horror movie so
shit's gonna go sideways and indeed it
absolutely does because then
zach starts talking really like talking
all this weird [ __ ] about like some
sort of being or some kind of energy
like in the woods that he's supposedly
like communicating with and he's just
like saying all this weird [ __ ] like
he's he takes pictures and he's talking
about like photography being like magic
and he has like a whole
dark room type situation set up in this
big like uh kind of
tent that he has going on
and uh so things just get
kind of a lot stranger and
more horrific from there
so i don't want to spoil any more of it
than that but if you loved a field in
england
um i can't see why you wouldn't enjoy
this one as well
it's definitely its own thing but it has
like a lot of similarities it has a lot
of the elements that um that made a
field in england so good
um it has that you know how a field in
england had this like flashy like trippy
like kaleidoscope type
uh visuals that felt like somebody dosed
you it has a lot of that kind of stuff
going on it has like some really cool
uh sound design like some really
unsettling sound design that's really
effective
it has a great score i got to say that
as well
and the whole theme of it it's almost
kind of talking about like the gaia
hypothesis i think they call it where
it's kind of like oh the earth is like a
sentient organism in some way
um and is sort of capable of
communicating to people
who know how to listen i guess
and it's also kind of exploring
um the way that this idea can be
approached either from a scientific
standpoint as dr wendell is trying to do
like communicating with the earth or
with this sentient
fungi or whatever it is
um and that the same idea can also be
approached from a more like spiritual
like pagan sort of
way like almost like a religious way
which is kind of what zack is doing like
it's more like ritualistic
and it's almost kind of like saying that
neither of those things are like
sufficient like maybe i don't know maybe
that's like maybe i'm reading too much
into maybe those it's like too big for
paltry humans to understand even though
we're trying to come at it from both
ways but yeah so it has like a theme
like that
um as i mentioned the film does have a
lot of uh flashing imagery and like
kaleidoscope type of stuff so you know
obviously if you have like some kind of
seizure disorder or something like that
the movie does have a warning at the
beginning he said hey there's all kind
of flashing images so you know if you
have a problem with that then obviously
you can't watch it um and as i said it's
pretty
grisly at times like it has like some
uh some bits of like real kind of like
body horror it's just more in the sense
of it being like realistic wounds and
injuries and [ __ ] like that um you know
just these gaping wounds like like i
said you see like somebody's foot
getting sewn up like this big gaping
wound in their foot being sewn up like a
loving close-up like somebody gets their
eye like gouged and it's just kind of
like it's pretty nasty so it's that you
know somebody gets their toes cut off
with an axe like [ __ ] like that so um so
if you're not into like real gruesome
[ __ ] like it's just bits it's not like
the whole thing isn't like wall to wall
gore or anything like that but there are
like these sort of like peroxisms of
of violence and like pretty nasty like
close-up kind of stuff uh i will say
that uh rhys shearsmith is great in this
uh he's great in everything i love him
but um yeah he's actually really
it's cool because he's like kind of
really friendly and like but but then
like he's real sinister as well like he
comes across really i don't know he's
really really creepy in this he's great
and so like i said if you like ben
wheatley's other movies then give this
one a watch um i'm sure you will enjoy
it like i said i didn't love it as much
as a field in england that one was like
a lot more
singular like unique
whereas this one reminded me a lot of
annihilation or midsummer it's not
exactly like those but it gave me much
more that kind of vibe where a field in
england was just its own kind of like
bizarro thing
but this has a lot of those elements to
it so if you like those if you like uh
folk horror if you like anything that's
real trippy like psychedelic like that
then you'd probably be really into this
so as i said it's streaming on hulu at
the moment and i'm sure it's elsewhere
as well so check it out if you've seen
it let me know what you think about it
in the comments and we'll have a
discussion about it and that'll do it
for this flickers of fear i'll see you
guys on the next one bye